bonjour tout le monde alors on se
retrouve avec avec les partis d'un
liquide et il a opposé cette fois ci à
jacques millet zeiss mitis je sais pas
comment on dit donc oui mon bon joueur
correct qui a eu le titre de grand var
être aussi qu'ils étaient allemands puis
partir en angleterre et voilà on attaque
la partie allait qui n'allait noir e4 e5
et d4 donc ouais c'est un oiseau rare de
nos jours mais ça existe toujours de
temps en temps il semble que dépôt avait
essayé de jouer ça d'autant entend
notamment partie rapide donc puis on
prend aidé à me prend alors bien sûr il
ya les trucs comme la gambie danois ou
quoi avec ses 3 qui existe mon général
je crois pas que les marques
il ya trop gourmand et normalement la
réponse appropriée tout jeu des cinq
pour justement se développer facilement
mais c'était pas le débat de la partie i
dames 34 calisesi sa tête la dame et
dames e3
donc en fait c'est un peu une sorte de
scandinaves inversé où ils savent plus
quoi là et donc l'idée des blancs sont
ses qualités trois fous des deux gros
rock et c'est d'aller attaquer les noirs
bah une partie de reproposer mais ce qui
en fait correspond pas mal au style
d'alquines ok il s'est développé avec
fos est alors à noter que en fait
cavalier v6 essence est plus précis
comme coup on le sait maintenant mais
éventuellement ils avaient peur de ce
qu'il faut se passer après ça kg 4 dames
bush qui prend le 5 qui on peut perdre
une pièce il ya vachement de jeux
eux-mêmes c'est mauvais pour les blancs
et donc c'était pas le truc qui voulait
jouer
j'imagine et il a commencé par fouet
cette voie là après une autre manière de
développer mutuellement cg 6 pourquoi
pas pour mettre le tout en faisant de
kétou sur une manne diagonale mais voilà
le coup approuvé par la théorie
maintenance etc car il est petit c'est
très bien et surtout comme kfc 3 on peut
se développer en clouant là-bas en b 4
et sur food et deux petits rock cran a
qui me semble que tour éviter le coup
voilà les blancs que je d'alger trois
mêmes semblent pousser tout reprend le 4
les blancs prennent pas en fait si on
prend qui les prend il ya des deux en
l'air il joua capture de moins c'est
trop des compensations je pense assez
floue comme compensation mais bon ok ça
peut se passer comme ça ok retour à la
partie dames 3 il n'a pas fait il a fait
flo7 bon le plan se développe avec food
et 2 il veut faire fi des docks et c3
comme d'hab juste éventuellement vu le
lord de complet par les noirs c'était
peut-être mal intenté d'alger 3 pour
directement l'attaqué de ce pion et il
pose et peut-être de trois questions
mais ok foulée de pourquoi pas
kelly et six essais 3 petit rock grand
roque et des cinq bonnes réactions
centrale irruption prendre cavalli
prendre et les blancs sont partis avec
la dame alors c'était pas forcément
géniale de prendre dans me prends pas ce
qu'ont fait les noirs regagner un temps
sur ce point donc on à boire un gamin
peut exploser au milieu c'était
peut-être pas grave y'a pas de
découverte totale en tout cas et
et voilà bon il a bougé et 1
et au passage il menace fourrage 6 qui
attaquera g7 et qui permettra à la tour
d'attaquer des cinq ans plus de
cavaliers donc ça serait une double
attaque donc là l'équipe trouvé un moyen
sympa de parer la menace il fait faux h4
donc ils attaquent la dame est il la
chasse de cette colonne en fait donc la
dame rouge et il se développe alors il
ya sûrement d'autres coûts no stress qui
en france et 3 par exemple pour pas
garder un peu ce vis-à-vis de clouage
mai
on va voir qu'elle avait une idée assez
brillante derrière la tête parce que
dessus avec les blancs en fait il a fait
faux 3 donc ça a l'air bien parce que en
attaque avec lecavalier avec la tour et
avec la dame ce cavalier en d5 donc de
bonne augure pour les blancs et surtout
qu'on peut pas vraiment le protéger ça
faisait ça les blancs pourraient prendre
une fois disons 10 nokia valley prend et
ses cadres donc gagne la pièce et s'il
faut prendre il ya un autre problème
s'est passé 4 s'attaque la dame mais
damage cinq attaques ici et menace
maintenant ces quatre prochains ok donc
ouais un peu pas juste défendre le
cavalier mais illégale ekin c'est
peut-être cette fille-là dames kim khai
pensait 3 et c'est assez impressionnant
parce qu'à l'époque
bon on respectait qu'un minable pour hp
toujours mais je veux dire à sept vis un
peu positionnelle de dame s'était pas
fréquent quoi donc là il donne la dame
pour une pièce une tour est un pion mais
qu'est ce qu'il a de plus dans la
position basse à dire qu'il a une bonne
activité des pièces les blancs tout ça
s'est pas développée donc ces pièces
sont pas mal avec les noirs la dame sait
pas trop quoi en faire avec sujette à
des attaques mais c'est parce que vite
gagnant pour autant c'est juste un peu
spéculatif long terme
ok les blancs se développe bon admettons
qu'il ya de qui vous êtes plus grand
chose très bien il vise un peu ces deux
éventuellement et puis on sait jamais si
on prend les caisses du roi cia pas
peut-être des prennent le long de la
première rangée quoi un cahier h3
développement autour du mythe place les
pièces très bien cavalier f4 et f5
attaque ses deux tours c'est un défunt
et le hockey ici allez king jouet un
coup il construit son attaque en fait il
est patient ou tel un prédateur il fait
j'ai six pour défendre son choix f5
éventuellement en assurant dans une
casse de fuite au roi parce que ouais
c'est en intentions parce qu'il a vu
évidemment c'était il est très fort en
tactique c'était cahiers français deux
temps repenser 2 qui est b4 dit ouais ça
c'est une bonne tête problème c est qu
il ya ce coup qui intercepte attaque le
fou et et voilà si on fait qu'il prend
des trois il ya des problèmes 5 sait pas
trop ce qu'on veut si un fait qui prend
ces données d'un problème 5 aussi et
donc voilà et si on fait un gouffre ou 4
alors les blancs peuvent rendre la dame
y les transposant ce genre de final qui
leur a quand même favorable puisqu'il y
aurait deux pièces pour la tour même
sans adoption quand même la paire de
fouet bien braquer c'est bien pour les
blancs seings ouais donc en fait qu'il
prend ces deux listes regardant réserve
mais après un autre coup qui pourrait
être jouable et qui était très bien
c'était qu'ils avaient des quatre
relativement actif place une pièce
au centre et par an il faut prendre tout
reprendre bon bah on verra qu'on s'a
continue mais mais c'était c'était
éventuellement une idée quoi ce qui
pourrait suivre serait pas bougé 5 à
voir ok il a fait g6 donc là les blancs
il joue pas mal il fait g4 chasse le fou
fou eux quatre ils bougent l'adar est en
fait il veut peut-être faire f3 ou fait
3 ou quoi pour échanger se foutrait
pénible et donc il ya eu il ya eu
quelques frissons qu'il rêve son fouquet
tu attaques un cap et du fefs aux trois
et ça c'est quand même pas mal pour les
blancs parce qu'ils ont enlevé le
dangereux fou donc il ya un échange et
donc avec le 5 ans regagne kane et tempo
sur la dame d'amiens 2 essais 5 c5
intéressant parce que dans l'optique
si les blancs font ces trois fait qu'il
voulait pouvoir venir ici et pas juste
se faire échanger
mais à voir ce coup de soutien pour
maintenir la pieuvre en d3 c'est une
pièce très très pénibles tour des ont
fait ces 4es ce cavalier c'est toujours
fort par rapport à cette tour se le
prend les colonnes celles là aussi en
eux et sur celle là elle est très
bloquée très forte sur pièce ouais donc
c'est un peu aidée de ses cinq donc et
il a fait tourner un bon bah du coup ils
fonctionnent les concurrents h4 donc les
blancs ne s'est pas éteinte une sorte de
contre attaque sait pas à quel point
c'est bienvenu mais pourquoi pas et puis
surtout ce qu'on sait c'est que
normalement quand on allait à dame de
plus faut justement attaqué créer des
faiblesses de leurs adverses et la dame
bien sûr c'est une pièce forte donc très
fort pour l'attack mais moins pour la
défense
donc f4 jouer et là un coup assez
brillant fait de la part d'un liquide
parce que f4 ses pertes juste très bien
sa tête ce cavalier si jamais qu'ils
allaient recul je sais pas par là bas il
ya dame français 4 s'était dit dépendant
levé le défenseur et au passage oui le
foulée 3-3 en l'air mais on a taxé de
tours ouais donc f4 salaire très fort et
là ce qu'elle et qui n'a joué c'est pas
mal ce qui est des trois alors c'est
quoi l'idée c'est que sur qui on prend
il voulait faire toi et donc attaquer
celui-là à fond et sur le tour j'ai
trois fers fou des cadres et donc il va
regagner la pièce simplement peut-être
les blancs de rentrer là dedans
jordan issifou prend les dames français
4 parce que bon on peut pas dire que
dans ce forcément mieux non plus enfin
c'est juste équilibre et d'ailleurs leur
dis mamie une vente de nuls qui était
comme ça droit à deux bons bien sûr pour
revenir sur la colonne s'est on se
prendra une enfilade et tour ici avec
dans l'idée éventuellement devenir
attaqué loin et sur ce genre de
variantes temps v6
même la tour c'est un bon la date doit
partir du coup un contrôle plus à 6
maintenant on va faire un chèque échec
et nuls quoi bon alors fait avant que
mon ordi suggérait met donc qui montre
que oui en fait ce cavalier prenable
mais c'est pas mieux pour les blancs bon
cela dit avec les blancs évidemment
il est même de plus et ils jouent pour
gagner il pense être mieux alors il fait
quoi il fait d'un mettra donc maintenant
ils menacent éventuellement bien sûr de
prendre le cavalier en plus ils
attaquent la tour donc là c'est logique
mais à l'équipe continue son jeu
brillant il fait tomber 5 et bien s'en
prendre au blanc et il attaque le pion
donc là maintenant soit en france on dit
oui peut-être b3 défend et b3 défend
rien du tout en fait il ya une suite
magnifique une vraiment jolie variante
donc ces tours à cinq créneaux veineuse
de maths
ok il faut prendre et l'appât tour 1
puisque le roi le roi s'échappe et qui
en a pas mieux que faire échec qui
permettent peut-être
et puis on prend des 3 donc on n'aurait
plus qu'une toit pour la dame mais le
pion dans cette case le fou prend celle
là est donc on menace toujours tours 1
pour mater droit donc quoi faire à part
tenter la suite
eh ben on prend encore les cases de fit
donc fait à nouveau buzz matt 3d un tour
un fou un fou c'est un pendant fort c
est ballot vous pouvez chercher comment
gagner c'est assez beau enfin c'est
vraiment bon ok j'ai spurs est mis en
pause et chercher le coup six tournois
alors pour ceux qui voulaient faire des
deux je dois dire que c'est pas mal vous
faites une dame
il prend en prend reprend et vous avez
une bonne finale par un avion de plus
vous pouvez couper le roi sur la seconde
rangée ou venir attaquer les pions ici
normalement signifierait qu'on va gagner
mais l'autre est plus joli plus les
puits plus fort en fait donc ses tours
tout reprend pim
on apprend et des deux fourchettes et en
fait le truc je n'y ai pas fini mais
c'est le roi ici on fait si on prend un
conte fée damian dame prend c'est trop
bon ok ce qu'un gagnant mais bon le
mieux c'est juste de prendre dans un
cavalier et refaire une fourchette
finale quoi donc assez joli coup
vraiment une belle variante mai
il n'est pas raisonnable dans la partie
d'appréhender trois hutois prend b2 race
est un et puis on prend des trois donc
toujours pareil en a qu'une tour pour la
dame on a trois pions et mais là par
contre droit qu'on l'emmène dans les
courants d'air et l'idée des noirs de
match sa blonde échec venir là et pour
ses huit tours ces deux et ça c'est deux
tours si pour mater un peu sorte de
maths de l'escalier pas ok il anticipe
le truc tour ses huit menace donc tour
ces deux est tombé à matt et il joue
j'ai cinq lots kaki qui est sûrement la
faute fatale ici à vrai dire l'ordi il
s'affole pas tellement il fait d'aveux 4
il veut venir taper espion et il donne
encore le plein de ventes où il ya 0 0
donc et souad et perpètrent des choses
comme ça mais bon on est là pour
regarder la partie
[Musique]
une autre idée de défense pour être tout
rejet de danse dire oui qu'il n'ira
pensée de avec la tour mais sa percée à
tour b 1 ils ont droit montrent la tour
revient la défense pions et donc on
menace pour ces deux maintenant qui est
cheikh leroy redescendre est et on m
avec cette tour ici donc le roi roja
doit repartir maintenant faut ces trois
donc walid et ça serait de de faire
éventuellement éventuellement ensuite
tourbe et un don comprend la case des
deux au roi blanc fou c'est un peu ça et
ça a paru très bien avec deux menaces
soient tour la catachrèse fou deux fois
avec deux tours soit même des deux qui
arriverait si on m'attaque la dame et en
os dame
trop de menaces partout mais donc ici
oui malgré la situation précaire durable
en dames e4 défendre et encore mais il a
fait g5 donc il faut hélas
donc très bien joué de la part de dali
kim qui descend la tour et qui menacent
le fameux maths en bien donc sur quoi
les blancs temps que la fuite
mais bon ça pas ça va servir à grand
chose
thouars b1 d'âme des uns est fou c'est
trois échecs et les yeux à bonbons mais
sur ce qu'on va gagner deux plats
matériel et même mater très rapidement
le roi blanc donc une partie assez
brillante créative statuettes de dames
qui était pas que les gagnants mais qui
donne partie difficile aux blancs
et puis il a bien trouver l'harmonie
avec ses pièces donc partie très
intéressante surtout en plus pour
l'époque
voilà à bientôt